ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FOR APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH.
NOTING IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE. I SEE
THAT WE HAVE OUR FIRST PRESENTER
MISTER COOLEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME UP.
YOU'RE GONNA WAIVE YOUR SUSPEND
SPELLS IN YOUR CONSENT BILL IN
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE IT ENJOYS
ONCE WE GET A CORPSMAN DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION.
.
THAT IS CORRECT MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND OF. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
FIVE RELATES TO CANNABIS PLANT.
OF THE MC RSA AND PROP SIXTY FOR
ALL COMMERCIAL CANNABIS IS
REQUIRED TO BE IN A.
TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM.
THE FOLLOWS A PRODUCT FROM ITS
INITIAL PLANTING TO ITS EVENTUAL
SALE.
AND.
THAT TRACK AND TRACE FITS
WITHIN THE INTENT OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR WHICH ENVISIONED A STRICT
CONTROL SYSTEM.
THROUGH THE WHOLE GROWTH
PROCESS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PRODUCT
REMAINS WHERE YOU WANT THE
PRODUCT TO BE IS NOT GETTING OFF
INTO THE BLACK MARKET.
.
SO TRACK AND TRACE IS ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE KEY LYNCH PINS WITHIN
THE PROP SIXTY FOUR SCHEME.
A.
AND EVEN ON THE BALLOT ARGUMENTS
IT WAS PRESENTED THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING TO FOLLOW BEST PRACTICE
OF OTHER STATES BECAUSE OF OTHER
STATES HAVE GONE THIS DIRECTION.
ARM. UNDER THE REGULATIONS
PROMULGATED BY THE CDFA A PLANTS
ARE.
NOT REQUIRED TO BE ISSUED A
UNIQUE IDENTIFIER FOR THIS.
LYNCH PIN TRACK AND TRACE
PROGRAM.
UNTIL THE PLAN IS MATURE.
AND THAT IS DEFINED AS A
FLOWERING PLANT.
NOW THAT'LL BE A CHALLENGE TO
ENFORCE IN VAST WAREHOUSE GROWS
BECAUSE YOU SORT OF HAVE TO
INSPECT.
THE STATUS OF EACH PLANT ON THE.
FLORIDA NON FLOORING CURVE OTHER
STATES TO AVOID THAT PROBLEM BY
SIMPLY APPLYING A HEIGHT
LIMITATION.
ONCE A PLAN REACHES A CERTAIN
HEIGHT IT'S DEEMED MATURE. AND
YOU CAN VISUALLY INSPECT LARGE.
WAREHOUSES OF PLANTS
BY THAT STANDARD VERY READILY.
A THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO.
IT WILL SET A STANDARD OF EIGHT
INCHES.
IN HEIGHT
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO THAT
STANDARD USED OTHER STATES.
.
SO.
ESTATE IN HOUSES COST TO SEE
THE FAA IN ANY CASE ARE EXPECTED
TO BE MINOR AND ABSORB RIPPLE.
AND I REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
A MIDDLE FILE.
YOU SEE NO QUESTIONS AS WE
CHECKED CLOSE.
GOSH DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES WILL TAKE
IT UP SINCE WE GET QUORUM THANK
YOU.
NEXT UP IS MISTER SOLACE.
MISTER SAUCIER BE PRESENTING ON
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN AND CHOICE
EIGHT TO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK GOD I'M CHERYL KEEP THIS
SHORT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN. IS A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
IS A SOUTH EXTENSION GOES TO THE
HEART OF DAIRY COUNTRY TO HELP
WITH GARY DIE JESTER SO.
AS YOU KNOW WITH THE ADVENT OF
CAP AND TRADE FROM LAST YEAR
OPEN ACTUALLY UTILIZE THIS.
MEASURE A LOT MORE.
FULLY IN THE UPCOMING FUTURE
SORT THAT RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN
ITEM.
ARE THERE ANY.
SUPPORTERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEY'RE ON
THEIR WAY.
NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT WHICH
ESTABLISHED ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHOI.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON TWENTY
FOUR FOURTEEN YEAR SUSPEND
SPELL.
MORNING THANK YOU WILL MADAM AND
UP COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAW.
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THEM IDEAL AB OUT TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN. THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIALLY OUR.
TO PREVENT A FIRE SH
THIS BILL LA WOULD OFFER A TAX
INCENTIVE CREDIT TO HOMEOWNERS.
A TO OFFSET.
THE A PURCHASER AND INSTALLATION
OF I ADDICT MANTA CLOSURE SYSTEM
FOURTH YEAR HOME IN ORDER TO
PREVENT FIRES.
AB TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN NOW
ORDER. HELP REDUCE FLY YOURSELF
FROM
SPREADING. A TO RESIDENTIAL OME
SELF DURING Y. FIRE BY PROVIDING
A TAX CREDIT OF UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
FOR THE PURCHASE AND
INSTALLATION OF WHAT ADDICTS
MENTAL CAUTIOUS.
THIS SET ADVANCED DUCK RUSSIA
SUCK CAN PREVENT
FIVE YOURSELF FROM SPREADING
INTO OUR HOUSES.
BY BLOCKING FLYING EMBERS
TYPICALLY.
BEALL FLYING EMBERS SAYS SUST
SUCKED INTO HOUSES OF TO REVEAL
OPEN VENTS.
OF SUCH AN IMPLAUSIBLE BENT
SYSTEM IS HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
ACCORDING TO THE ORANGE COUNTY
FIRE OFFICIALS.
I CONSULTED WITH.
VENDORS.
OF WHO CAN INSTALLED IS TO ADD
TO EXPAND.
A CLOSER SYSTEM SO HAVE BEEN
APPROVED AND THEN ALSO. A LISTED
DEL MONTE CALIFORNIA WEBSITES.
THERE'S YOU KNOW A CALIFORNIA
HAS SOME FACED THAT A NUMBER BUT
FIRE SAW.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AND.
IN THE PAST YEARS.
SEVERAL OF FIRE CHIEFS ARE HAVE
A STADIUM A FAIRLY SIMPLE WAY TO
PREVENT THE FIRES OF FROM
DESTROYING HOMES IS TO INSTALL.
ATTIC VENTS TOOK WILL SHOW
SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY ERA A WIN ON AMBER
GUESTS ARE IN TOWN AND THE
COMMAND TO THE FIRE ESPRESSO.
THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE.
THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE OF HIS HIS
KIA MAIN WAY THAT THAT MEMBERS
ARE GETTING INTO HOUSES TALK AND
DESTROYING THEM DOING TO WATCH
FIVE YEARS.
OF FOR A FAIR PRIZE SOUTH THERE
ARE SOME VENDORS SO WHO CAN THIS
STONE ADDICT AND TO CRUCIAL SO
ON HOME. WHICH WERE NOT THE BILL
WITH US SUCH GROW SHOWS.
THIS VENDORS I HAD BEEN APPROVED
BY THE OF HOTEL FIRE. AND UNLESS
I STATED THAT THEY ARE LISTED ON
THEIR WEBSITES.
IN ADDITION A RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT SO.
A YEAH ONE EIGHTH INCH
MATCHING INSTALLED AROUND THE
ATTIC MANTLE OPENING CELL OR SO
WE'RE.
PROTECTING HOMES.
I'M FROM OUR MEMBERS ARE
ENTERING OUT THROUGH THE ATTIC
VENTS.
BUT THE FIRE CHIEFS ARE THAT
HIGH OF A MET THE WITH.
AT THE SET AND EXPAND SO GROCERS
SYSTEMS ARE OVER NINETY FIVE
PERCENT EFFECTIVE.
AT THE KIDDING FIRE EMBERS SAW
OUT OF THE HOMES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
DUSTIN CALIFORNIA FACED OUT ONE
OF THE WORST YEAR SITE AND
CALIFORNIA WIFI HISTORY.
ONE FIRE DESTROYED WHAT DAMAGE
THE MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND OF
STRUCTURES.
IN NOT CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
THIS.
DESTRUCTION DOT TO TWO FIRES IS
SOME MORE THAN. WHAT I WAS STATE
HAS PHASE STUCK IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS SO COMBINED?
THEN NAPA AND THAT'S SO MUCH
ONLY FIVE ALL ALONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
I TOOK FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
HOMES.
IT WAS THE THIRD DEADLIEST A
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA SO HISTORY
KILLING TWENTY TWO PEOPLE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY ALL BY DE JA
DESTRUCTION WAS SO MUCH LESS
THAN THE. CENTS CENTRAL AND ON
THE LONG CALIFORNIA TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SO THE ACT CANYON. UP
TO FIRE WHICH DESTROYED OF
TWENTY FIVE STRUCTURES AND OF
DAMAGE. DAMAGES FIFTY FIVE
HOUSES I PERSONALLY HAD THE TWO
OFF THE DAMAGED AREAS.
ACCORDING TO OUR TERRIFYING OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTY IN OUT WAS
THE OUT MOST OF DESTRUCTIVE WERE
AND THE DEADLY.  ARE AWFUL
FILE YES OF FOR CALIFORNIA A
TOTAL OF NINE THOUSAND.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE FIVE
YEARS UP BURNED.
WHICH INCLUDED THE.
MORE THAN ONE POINT THIRTY.
MILLION ACRES.
THIS SUBTEXT INCENTIVE IT AS
SUCH A SMART INVESTMENT IN ORDER
TO IN ORDER TO PROTECT THAT THE
PEOPLE AND A HOME SO IN
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN KEEPING UP OUR
STATE AND HOME SO SAY FOR. BY
PREVENTING.
THE SPREAD OF OF FIVE YEARS. IN
THE VOTING AYE ON AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE WE ARE WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT WE
WOULD KNOW THAT.
FTP ESTIMATES REVENUE LOSSES OF
TWENTY NINE MILLION EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
AND.
TWENTY AND HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU.
SEE NOW QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
HAS GRAY AYE RULED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI THIS'LL BE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MISTER PATTERSON AYE NURSING
YOUR WHAT YOUR YOU READY.
OKAY.
MR CHOW.
I GET YOU TO PRINT THAT'S.
THANK YOU KNOW.
NOW EVERYBODY.
MR CHOW.
.
IT'S GONNA BE PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR WOULD AMEND THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE. TO ENSURE THAT
THE STANDARDS USED BY STATE
AGENCIES TO PROCURE NON IT
CONTRACTS ALSO APPLY TO IT
CONTRACTS UNDER CURRENT LAW. OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES WITH THE GS HAS GENERAL
STATE CONTRACTING AUTHORITY FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES. HOW IT
PROHIBITS A AGENCIES TO ENTER
INTO LARGE SCALE NON IT
CONTRACTS WITH VENDORS WHO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST EMPLOYEESIN
THE PROVISION OF BENEFITS ON
THE BASIS OF THEIR GENDER?
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP STATUS
VENDORS WHO HAVE LARGE SHOT TAX
DELINQUENCIES ARE AMONG OTHERS.
NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TOOK A CD TEACHERS
AUTHORITY WITH EDS OVER THE
PROCUREMENT OF IT GOODS AND
SERVICES.
YET.
THEIR PROCUREMENT NOW PROCESS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS.
I IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE
SURE THE SAME POLICIES ARE
ADHERE TO ACROSS THE BOARD ON
NOT JUST IN PRACTICE BUT AS A
MATTER OF LAW.
THIS BILL WILL.
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES CD TO THE
COMPLY WITH THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS ARE ON OUR THE GSL
SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR CHOW ARE THERE ANY
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HOW WE HAVE NO POSITION AT THIS
TIME BUT WE NOTE THAT FROM
TECHNOLOGY AND DG ES BOTH
ESTIMATE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
COSTS?
ONE OF.
THANK YOU.
WHICH I CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER ABOUT I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAN.
STILL IT MISTER PATTERSON RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO HAVE
MISTER WOULD THEN DOCTOR WOULD.
WE ARE STILL IN A SUBCOMMITTEE
FAT.
DOCTOR WOULD WILL BE PRESENTING
ON A FEW BILLS.
AB IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO START WITHOUT YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENJOYED THE
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU.
THIS BILL REQUIRES APPLICANTS
FOR SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
LICENSE TO DISCLOSE TO THE
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WHETHER
OR NOT THE APPLICANT OR THEIR
PARTNER AYE HASN'T OWNERSHIP OR
CONTROL INTEREST OF FIVE PERCENT
OR MORE IN A BUSINESS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY.
SOME SNIFFS A CONTRACT OUT BASIC
FUNCTIONS LIKE MANAGEMENT OR
RENT THEIR OWN BUILDING FROM
SISTER CORPORATION ROBIN
INTEREST THE COMPANY THAT DOES
THE LAUNDRY.
SNIFF OWNERS ARE THEN ESTABLISH
HIGHLY FAVORABLE CONTRACTS IN
WHICH THERE NURSING HOMES PAY
MORE FOR SERVICES NAY MY IN A
COMPETITIVE MARKET.
THIS ALLOWS HIM TO SIPHON OFF
HIGHER PROFITS WHICH ARE NOT
RECORDED IN THE NURSING HOME
ACCOUNTS.
SNIPS OF MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE BASED ON THEIR COSTS
SO IF THEY'RE INFLATING THEIR
COSTS THERE ALSO POTENTIALLY
RAISING THEIR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES COSTING THE STATE MONEY.
THE SIMPLEST BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY REGARDING
STEPS PRACTICES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALL.
SURE THAT YEAH GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS VIRGINIA FAIR ON THE
TONY. I AM A VOLUNTEER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ART A.
TEAM AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ARE IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
KNOW.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WILL TAKE THAT UP
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM. NEXUS AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE IT ALSO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE REQUIRES A BY TWENTY TWENTY
ALL MEDICATION PRESCRIBERS AND
DISPENSERS WILL HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO HE PRESCRIBED. IT
FOR THE REQUIRES A BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE E. PRESCRIBING FOR
MOST PRESCRIPTIONS WOULD BE
REQUIRED. THE RATIONALE FOR THIS
BILL IS TOO FULL FIRST E.
PRESCRIBING IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO ADDRESS THE OPIOID CRISIS BY
REDUCING THE AVAILABILITY. OF
OPIOIDS ATTEND OBTAINED THROUGH
THREE PART FRAUDULENT MEANS.
SECOND E. PRESCRIBING WOULD
REDUCE MEDICATION ERRORS MORE
THAN ONE POINT THREE PEOPLE ARE
INJURED MILLION PEOPLE ARE
INJURED BY MEDICATION ERRORS
ANNUALLY IN THE UNITED STATES
AND MOST OF THESE MISTAKES ARE
PREVENTABLE.
DESPITE WHAT YOU MIGHT HEAR E.
PRESCRIBING IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ONE
POINT SIX BILLION PRESCRIPTIONS
WERE ALREADY ISSUED
ELECTRONICALLY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AS FAR BACK AS TWO THOUSAND
THREE THAT CENTERS FOR DISEASE
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
INCLUDING E. PRESCRIBING AND IN
THE MEDICARE MODERNIZATION ACT.
NINE STATES INCLUDE WITH LARGE
POPULATIONS LIKE NEW YORK AND
SMALLER MORE RURAL STATES LIKE
MAINE RIDE RHODE ISLAND HAVE
PASSED THE PRESCRIBING LAWS.
IT'S NO LONGER FUTURE TECHNOLOGY
IT EXISTS IT'S READILY AVAILABLE
AS TIME HAS COME.
ADOPTION OF TECHNOLOGY TO
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A HALLMARK OF THE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSION. ADOPTING
THE PRESCRIBING IS NO EXCEPTION
IMPORTANT ELEMENT IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF PATIENT CARE REDUCING
PRESCRIPTION FOUGHT FRAUD AND
ULTIMATELY SAVING LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF.
THINK YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE
SOME WITNESSE I'M GONNA REMIND
WITNESSES THAT.
WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO NO
MORE THAN TWO WITNESSES PER SIDE
NO MORE THAN?
TWO MINUTES AND TRY TO KEEP IT
TO THE FISCAL.
AND PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION TO BEGIN WITH
GOOD MORNING SHOWER REAVIS WITH
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ALL THE REASONS DOCTOR WHAT
STATE IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK UP PRAYER.
HERE ON BEHALF OF MCKESSON
CORPORATION.
WE ALSO URGE OUR I VOTE IN
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS BY SOME
REMEMBER WHAT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
AND OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOVA.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I WOULD JUST CLOSE TO ELECT
LAST I. THINK YOU THINK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU READY NOW
HA.
MISTER PATTERSON I SEE YOU'RE
GONNA PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE ITEM
IT'S AB TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN.
I THINK ABOUT A CHAIR APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THAT
TWENTY TWO A SIXTEEN UP.
A MEMBER SANTIAGO AND I ARE UP
REQUESTING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS BE ALLOCATED AND WITH
CAL O. YES. FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OF VICTIM ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO INCREASE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TRAINING ON THIS
ISSUE AND TO CONDUCT A
PREVALENCE STUDY. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS HAPPENING CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND I
ALSO ARE WORKING ON AN IDENTICAL
REQUEST TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE?
OVER THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO GIVE NON
PROFITS THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAN
AHEAD. BETTER BY SHOWING THEM
THAT THIS OF FUNDING IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
IS MOVING FORWARD ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RESOURCE CENTER CALIFORNIA HAS
THE. MOST REPORTED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE NATION.
IT IS THROUGH THE WORK OF THESE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AT
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING CAN
BE RESCUED BROUGHT. I'M TO A
LIFE OF RECOVERY THESE
ORGANIZATIONS OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TEMPORARY
HOUSING COUNSELING JOB TRAINING.
AND THE CHANCE FOR A NEW LIFE
OUR STATE THAT HAS APPROVED
SIMILAR FUNDING FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS WERE ASKING FOR
CONTINUED STATE INVESTMENT. IF
WE'RE UP GOING TO COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING EFFECTIVELY AND HELP
RESTORED OF THE LIVES OF THE
SURVIVORS.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY MELANIE
CUEVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING KNOWS CAST
BASED OUT OF LOS ANGELES HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY ON.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE START THAT
IF IT'S OKAY I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO STEP MUCH WARM.
AND SECRETARY.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
CALDERON.
CARILLO HERE
CHECK OUT YET EGGMAN. FONG.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER
GARCIA. NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE QUIRK HERE WITH.
HERE.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THAT OPPORTUNITY IF YOU ARE AYE
SUPPORTERS WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MONIQUE ME THIS WITH A CAN TOM
AKERS COMPANY I AM CAST PRO BONO
LOBBYIST CAST IS THE SPONSOROF
THIS MEASURE. I'M CAST IS ALSO
THE LARGEST IN FOR SERVICE
PROVIDER IN THE UNITED STATES
SERVING MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
VICTIMS OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY OR
SERVICES PER PROVIDED INSIST
HE'S.
CASE MANAGEMENT LEGAL SHELTER
AND WE ALSO SERVICE THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR HOTLINE THAT IS POSTED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE HOTLINE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ALONE RECEIVED OVER FOUR
THOUSAND CALLS.
AND TODAY WE'RE HAPPY TO.
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR THIS REQUEST
FOR FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
THIS IS OUR FOURTH YEAR MAKING
THIS REQUEST IN FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE. OF
FUNDING ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS.
THROUGH THE PAST THREE YEARS
WORTH OF FUNDING WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND TWENTY ONE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND NOW
ALMOST EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE
HAS ACCESS TO AT LEAST ONE
SERVICE PROVIDERFOR VICTIMS.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN ALMOST FOUR
THOUSAND VICTIMS WERE SERVED AND
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND SERVICES WERE PROVIDED
ALLOWED.
AND THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST ALSO IN ADDITION TO.
GRANTS FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
INCLUDES INCREASED TRAINING FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS OF PREVALENCE
STUDY OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
EVALUATION.
WRITERS
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ONCE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
FUNDING IN THE ANTI.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU. TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN RELEASE
ORTEGA'S WITH WALKER GROUP ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CHARITIES AND CALIFORNIA AT THE
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
OPPOSITION.
PART OF FINANCE.
NOVELL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER SANTIAGO IT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SPEAKER ME TOO. I THINK.
ALRIGHT.
.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH ACT
CLOSE.
ALL THAT THAT WE ARE GOING GREAT
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPEND
SOUND THANK YOU.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU AND GO AHEAD
AND STAFF.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING ON A B.
THIRTY FORTY TWO IT DOES ENJOY
DO PASS AS AMENDED. ADD TO AMEND
SECTION FOUR FIVE TWO OF THREE
OF THE EDUCATION CODE TO DEEMED
PRESIDENT STAY IN INTERNATIONAL
WORKERS DAY. PAID HOLIDAYS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHOOSE TO
OBSERVE THEM CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT LAW FROM WASHINGTON DAY
AND THINKING DAY. WHICH OUGHT TO
PROCEED MOVE THE BILL.
LEYVA MADAM CHAIR LIKE THAT
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND REQUEST EITHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GIVE MONEY
MISTER OR MISS MADAM CHAIR
EXCUSE ME THIRD WHATEVER WHEREAS
COLLEGE GUYS NIGHT OF CHAIR. OF
RON RAP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF MAYBE THIRTY
FORTY TWO THIS ALLOWS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EDUCATORS TO
COMMEMORATE THE STRUGGLES OF.
LABOR ACTIVISTS AND.
TO.
COMMEMORATE THE HARD FOUGHT
VICTORIES THAT THEY HAD IN TERMS
OF GETTING A FORTY HOUR WORK
WEEK AND WEEKENDS OFTEN BENEFIT
SIX THAT ARE EXCITED ABOUT. IT
ALSO PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
EDUCATORS TO TEACH STUDENTS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
LABOR MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
AND.
THE HISTORY OF OUR GREAT STATE
SO.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOVELL.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD OWE
MISTER BIGELOW DOES HAVE A
QUESTION.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE.
LABOR.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE DAY THAT
WE HAVE WHICH.
LABOR DAY.
ONE OF THEM'S ABOUT THE.
U. S. WORKERS ONE OF THEM AS
ABOUT INTERNATIONAL WORKERS.
.
BROADENS.
SO THIS IS AN INTERNATIONAL
WORLDWIDE DAY THEN YEAH.
I'M TRYING TO HELP COULDN'T YES
ABSOLUTELY. LITTLE CONNECT WITH
OTHER.
THEY WILL HAVE THE SAME.
IT'S ACTUALLY CELEBRATED IN
SIXTY SIX COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE WORLD ON THE US IS
THE ONLY COUNTRY THAT DOESN'T
REALLY CELEBRATE IT EVEN THOUGH
THE LABOR MOVEMENT STARTED IN
THE U. S..
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO COMMEMORATE THEY
SAY JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
WHY DID WE JUST RENAME LABOR DAY
TO.
BECAUSE IT WENT ONLINE BUT THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
MAY FIRST IS INTERNATIONAL
WORKERS OKAY SO IT'S JUST THE
DATE SPECIFIC JUST
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK WE HAVE JUST
SHOWN WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RAISE THE AWARENESS OF
INTERNATIONAL WORKERS DAY.
SOME OF US.
LEARN IT OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL BUT I
DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE LEARN IT
IN SCHOOL.
.
WHICH YOU LIKE CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY THOUGH.
I A WILL TAKE THAT UP AS SOON AS
WE GET A FEW MARK BUT DEMOCRATS
HERE THANK YOU IN CONCERT
.
MRS COMING ADAM.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY NINE AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH
WOULD INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY
OF SAFE STORAGE DEVICES IN
PHARMACY SO ESTA SECURE
DANGEROUS AND ADDICTIVE
MEDICATIONS AT HOME.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOVELL.
THAT HAS A MOTION BY MISTER
SQUARE QUIRK AND SECOND BY
MYSTERIOUS.
WHICH I CLOSE.
WE KNOW THAT DAD THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF THE AND SAFE STORAGE OF
OPIOIDS YET IN HOMES IS.
PARTICULARLY ACUTE IN THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT'S A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANSTON IS WE GET A FEW
MORE PEOPLE HERE WILL TAKE THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS AT THIS
TIME IN THE AUDIENCE WILL GO
AHEAD AND.
TAKE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE THE MOTION BY MISTER BELOW A
SECOND BY MISTER BONTA. AND
SECRETARY WE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY NINETY FIVE TWENTY ONE ON
NINE TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO
TWENTY THREE OH ONE TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. TWENTY THREE NINETY
ONE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY NINE TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX TWENTY BY THIRTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE TWENTY FIVE
FORTY ONE TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY. TWENTY SIX
SIXTY ONE TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
NINE TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE FORTY FOUR TWENTY NINE
FORTY NINE. THIRTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY THIRTY SIX THIRTY FORTY
SEVEN THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVENTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE TWELVE
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT AND. THIRTY TO THIRTY.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
I NOW THAT WE ARE STILL WAITING
ON MR MEDINA BUT NOW THAT MISTER
BLOOM IS HERE.
WE CAN TAKE UP.
LET'S TAKE A LET'S START WITH A.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE BY
MISTER COOLEY TERM MOTION.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MYSTERIOUS A
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK PACKETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN BY MISTER SOLACE.
I HAVE THEM MOTION BY MYSTERY AS
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO THAT
GETS OUT ON AN A ROLL CALL WITH
THE CHAIR NOT VOTING AND MISTER
BLOOM NOT VOTING.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY MR
CHOW.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS REYES.
A SECOND BY.
MISTER QUIRK.
THAT GETS OUT.
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
EXCEPT MISTER OBERNOLTE AND
MISTER GALLAGHER WHO OUR EYES.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY THREE BY
MISTER WOOD.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISS KOREA A
SECOND BY MISS RAY S..
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
MISTER WOOD.
THE MOTION BY MISS KOREA A
SECOND BY MISS RAY S..
THAT GETS OUT ON A BE A ROLL
CALL.
WITH.
MR FUNG AND MR GALLAGHER NOT
VOTING.
AND MR SANTIAGO'S THIRTY FIVE
FORTY TWO HAS A MOTION A SECOND
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
EIGHT.
IN BE.
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE.
COME BY AT ALL ISN'T. IT
SORRY LET ME ASSURE GET THAT
RIGHT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THAT GETS OUT ON II B. ROLL CALL
AND I'M WITH.
MISTER GALLAGHER VOTING I AM
MISTER FUNG AND MR PEROT NOT
VOTING.
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU FOR GRACING US WITH
YOUR PRESENCE YOU ARE I THINK
LAST PRESENTER.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
MOVE YOUR BILL AND MEMBERS.
VERY QUICKLY VERY.
SPECIFICALLY ABA EIGHTEEN%
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
DREAMERS TO SERVE ON BOARDS I
THINK IT'S AN. IMPORTANT DATA. A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE A.
THAT THEY SHOULD ENJOY.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOUARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHAN
LIFE IN A BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
THINK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOVA.
NO QUESTIONS YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
SPEC WE ASK YOUR.
I VOTE.
THINKING THAT WAS A MOTION BY
MISTER PARK AS SECOND BY MISS
RACING THAT GETS OUT.
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES THE PEOPLE WHO'LL
HAVE TO TESTIFY THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR SOME REASON MISTER
GLORIA DID SIGN AND BUT I DON'T
SEE A BILL FOR HIM SO.
HOPEFULLY THAT WAS JUST A
MISTAKE.
WE DO NEED TO READ THE ITEMS
THAT WERE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
WHILE NOW MA'AM SECRETARY.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN FIVE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN SIXTY TO
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. NINETEEN THIRTEEN
NINETEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY FIFTY THREE TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
ONE TWELVE TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FIFTY.
THREE TO NINETY FIVE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE TWENTY THREE
THIRTY NINE TWENTY THREE FIFTY
NINE TWO THREE SIXTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
FORTY ONE TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY ONE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE TWENTY SIX OH TWO TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY
THREE. TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY TWENTY SEVEN OR. TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE.
THREE SEVEN EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
OH FIVE TWENTY EIGHT OO EIGHT
TWENTY FORTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO. TWENTY NINE SIXTY
ONE TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
THIRTY TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
THIRTY ONE NINETY FIVE AND
THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU ANYBODY WISHES TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL THAT WAS MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE PILE ON THE
AUTHOR WAY PRESENTATION PLEASE
COME FORWARD NOW.
SEEN THAT NOT.
BUT.
KATHY SHARON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA WE JUST WANTED TO.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE AB
TWENTY THIRTEEN CUNNINGHAM.
WE THINK IT'S AN UNNECESSARY
CHANGED TO THE.
EXISTING PROVISIONS OF THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
THANK YOU.
LIVE ONE WHERE.
GOOD MORNING I MEAN TOWER ON
BEHALF OF ARMY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THINK
YOU THINK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PRESENTATIONS
TODAY I'M IN A WHOLE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS INTO
RECORD VOTES FOR.
.
MANY GIVE THEM TWO MINUTES.
AND AFTER THAT WE'LL BE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU
OFFICIALLY CLOSED.
ADJOURNED